新进来的粉丝朋友们
左上角的小心心帮我点赞点起来
我们这里是专业的
关于你情感方面
关于你获取女性资源
关于你怎么去约会
怎么去约好一个会
怎么样去接触一个女生
的一个情感频道好吗
如果说还没有加入我
的粉丝团的兄弟们
点亮粉丝灯牌
花一分钱点亮粉丝灯牌
成为我的一个老粉
然后每天来跟我一起学习
早点可以获得情感自由好吗
进来的兄弟们左上角
小心心点赞点起来啊
点赞点起来
进来先点赞好吗
进来先点赞
兄弟们进来先点赞
如果说你还没有加入我的粉丝团
花一分钱点亮我们的一个粉丝灯牌
早点成为一个老粉好吧
进来的兄弟们左上角
点赞点赞点赞点起来
待会我们开始进行答疑了
呃可以连麦
待会再连吧
因为现在还没多少人
待会过个几分钟
过个几分
过个十来分钟
9:10可以开始连麦
9:10开开始连麦
b站的这位兄弟
我们等一下其他的粉丝朋友
等一下其他兄弟们
新进来的兄弟们
左上角点赞点起来
小心心点起来
进来先点赞
礼貌白嫖
做一个做一个礼貌的白嫖粉丝好吗
做一个礼貌的白嫖粉
如果说你还没有加入我的粉丝团
花一分钱点亮粉丝灯牌
然后加入我的粉丝团
早点成为老粉
然后每天跟我一起学习
跟我一起进步
进来先点赞
进来先点赞好吧
进来新进来的粉丝
新进来的朋友先点赞
左上角的小心心
点赞点起来
点赞点起来好吗
还没有加入我的粉丝团的兄弟们
花一分钱点亮粉丝灯牌
早点加入我的粉丝团
然后跟我一起每天跟我一起学习
跟我一起成长
跟我一起进步
不想进步吗
兄弟们不想进步吗难道
占了直直播100次可以
很棒占了100次
非常棒
呃连麦的话在抖音啊
连麦的话在抖音
不要在视频号连麦
去抖音跟我连麦
对去抖音
我在我们的会员群发
的一个直播的链接
去跟我连麦
假皮我像哪吒
对因为现在天气天气比较炎热嘛
天气比较炎热
我基本上没有
除了除了我要去除了我要去出镜
我要去可能录节目
或者说我要去见一个
甚至我见我见女生都是这个发型
懂吧
因为它足够的稀少
因为它足够的有吸引力
因为它有足够的有吸引力
所以说我才会
懂吗反其道而行之
因为大家都在因为
大家都在一样的发型一样的
一样的动作
一样的一样的妆造
一样的穿搭
所以说你需要你
需要怎样去脱颖而出
脱颖而出的概念是什么
孔雀理论的概念是什么
兄弟们知道吗
孔雀理论的概念
有兄弟说差异化打法
就是你要足够的稀少
好吧
你要足够的有稀缺性
当所有人都是那样的时候
你就不是那样
你管他是丑的好的什么乱七八糟的
对不对
但前提是还是要有一定的审美啊
你不能说所有人都很干净
你故意整得很很臭很邋遢
那样是不行的
你得是正向的
你得是正向的脱颖而出
正向的稀缺性好吧
懂不懂
正向的稀缺性
呦等一下
你必须得是正向的稀缺性
新进来的兄弟们
左上左上角的小心心
帮我点赞点起来好吗
点赞点起来
点赞先进来先把点赞点起来
然后还没有加入我
的粉丝团的兄弟们
花一分钱点亮我的粉丝灯牌
成为我们的一个老粉
每天给大家直播答疑
每天给大家讲干货
让你进步
让你获得情感自由
让你变成一个撩妹大神知道吗
撩妹大神
多么可怕
多么可怕的一个
多么可怕的一个名号
撩妹大神
早日达到你的什么百词斩
百词斩选手
早日成为一个百词斩选手
各位都有没有百词斩
各位有没有
今天百词斩了吗
今天有没有百次展
兄弟们今天有没有百次展
如果说你今天还没有百次展
那么你就更加需要学习
你就更加需要学习
主播撩过多少
我都不说撩过多少了
撩过的肯定是数不过来的
就我约过的
约会过的肯定是数不过来的
但如果说你要说诶
收尾了几个
推倒了几个
其实也数不过来
因为在达到可能60来个左右
就没去计数了
就没去计数了真的
我现在记
可能有些收尾过的我都他
就是有没有这个人我都记不住了
我不知道你们有没有这种感觉
就是久了之后
有没有这个人你都忘了
懂吗有没有这个人你都忘了
真的会有这样的情况
你的事情太多了
你对于女性的
你对于女性
你对于女生的一个所有的体验
知道吗所有的体验
都已经经历了之后
你真的你对同样的一个有
两个眼睛一个嘴巴的
如果说他没有很
他没有给你很深刻的印象
没有给你很深刻的记忆
你是真的记不住他的
有的兄弟说还是阈值问题
对你同样的
你为什么很多人他很多幻想的
你知道所谓的百词斩
很所谓的百词斩
三个字百词斩
为什么都只是屌丝们
或者说一些没有经历过这样
的一个体验的人的一个幻想
为什么为什么
为什么因为同样的东西你吃多了
除非你是一个有数量收集癖的选手
但同时你还要有很好的技术
很好的运气以及足够的耐心
你可能能达到百次斩
但是
大多数情况是
你每天吃同样的东西
你每天吃火锅
或者说你每天吃牛排
你都会把自己吃吐你以后
稍等一下啊
你在以后的一个节点里面
你在之后的日子里面某一天
你看到牛排你都想吐
你看到火锅你都想吐知道吧
这是人的
大脑的多巴胺阈值决定的
多巴胺阈值决定的
就是你的多巴胺
上限就决定了你可以
能不能做到百次战
你的多巴胺上限决定的
你这个人
呃你有一些人哈
有一些人他的多巴胺上限很低
他多巴胺上限很低什么人
就是那种容易得容易得抑郁症的人
容易得焦虑症的人
容易焦虑的人
那种人他的一个
多巴胺上限非常的低
所以他容易焦虑
所以他容易
他满足了之
他容易满足了之后就开始
对这个事情失去兴趣了懂吗
这种人是很难达到百次展的
只有那些只有那些就是
很难达到多巴胺上限
多巴胺阈值的那些人
他才容易
也不能容易
就也很难
你同样一个东西
你每天吃同样的东西
真的要吃吐
很难达到百分
所以说我真的
我到了可能60多个左右我真的
这碗饭我是吃吐了兄弟们
这碗饭我是吃吐了
所以说之后
不想去数了
你知道吗
不想去记了
而且我本身我在哪怕在60个之前
我也没有去计数的习惯啊
就我对这个东西真的不care
我专注于什么细节
还有技术手段
技术水平
专注于教学
可能复制性这一块好吧
好我们换一个话题来聊
有
抖音上有一个兄弟说
鹌鹑蛋这个兄弟
请问外国女生好搭讪吗
都一样的呀
都一样的
按照我们的搭讪的5个锁定5个锁定
哪五个锁定
哪5个锁定
给新给我们的新粉丝
给我们的新的兄弟去科普一下
哪5个锁定
有兄弟知道吗
第一个是什么
力度锁定对吧
第一个是力度锁定
先要碰到他的肩
为什么不叫碰肩锁定
为什么不叫触碰锁定
为什么要叫力度锁定
因为我们的力度是有一个标准的
是有一个标准的
第一步是力度锁定
第一步不是眼神
第一步也不是角度
第一步是力度锁定
碰到他的肩是有
一定的力度的把控的
不是说啪
很大的力气把人家直接打飞
把人家一掌打死
也不是很轻
哎那种碰一下
像一个销售怪人一样
像一个像一个很猥琐的很
很猥琐的性骚扰怪人一样
那种很轻的去碰女的
这种也不行好吧
这种也不行
就是说我们是有一个标准的力度的
把力度锁定了之后
再是什么
再是眼神锁定
这个眼神锁定是
马上接着力度锁定的
而且眼神锁定之后
他不能马上离开
他还需要锁定一段时间
那么这个时间
这个锁定的时间
我们也是有标准的
锁定的时间也是有标准的
眼神锁定了之后才是什么
才是角度锁定才是角度锁定
这个角度我们也有衡量标准的懂吧
对外我们是对45度角45度角
不是90度也不是180度
是45度给我记住45度
好然后你的角度锁定了
你还有距离锁定
懂吗距离锁定
我们也是一个标准距离的
懂吗它是一个模板
所有的我们我们在搭讪
里面的所有行为都有
都是标准化的
都是标准化
它都有指标的
我们的搭讪有100多个注意事项
他不是你上去噼里啪啦
胆子大要一个号就完事了
他是需要有
我们是有一套标准体系的
有一套打分体系的
你哪里哪里有没有做标准
不你做
你只要把这个东西做标准
它的成功率就会非常可怕
而且它的成功率
不是去收号的成功率是你在
搭讪里面
是你在这个搭讪的场景里面
你能获得很高的吸引力
是这样的一个逻辑
我们不是去收号
甚至于我们会让学员
我们会让学员不要带手机
就全部不要碰手机
全部让女的加他
全部让女生去加他知道吗
我们是这样的一个技术手段
最后一个锁定最后一个锁定对吧
刚刚说了4个
最后一个锁定就是我们的开场白
这个时候才说开场白
很多人一上去就说开场白懂吗
这个是区分
所以说你要说
你要问我外国女生好搭吗
都是一样的
因为我们有国外的学员
在国外的搭是用的一样的体系
就照样能拿结果知道吧
照样能拿结果
就区别在于你的语言的一些问题
好吧如果说你的语言真的很垃圾
你上去可能就是诶excuse me
i just want to say
呃you're absolutely beautiful
呃i want your Instagram对吧
你直接要他的ins账号
或者说i want your Wechat就ok了
非常简单
take it easy
对吧
前就是你只需要把那几个锁定做到
然后说出你的开场白
吸引自然就来了
前提是你要做标准懂吗
前提是你得做标准
你做不标准吸引就出不来
你说的什么女人可能都
他不是听听不明白
他是怀疑你这个人的意图
你这个人是来耍他的
是来销售的
还是说真正来撩他的
他会从你的神情
你的肢体语言
从我们的整个一套
标准里面观察出来好吧
所以说外国女生照样可以搭
用我们这套体系
没有任何的一个
没有任何的一个区别
有区别只是你言语上的
你们语言之间的问题
好我们看一下呃
视频号这个甘宁这个兄弟说
杰哥挽回只能走高价值回归吗
你要知道
我告诉你
你知道讲价吗
就是甘宁这个兄弟
你知道讲价怎么讲的吗
讲价谈崩了
你俩讲价讲崩了
诶这个商家说这个商家说
我这个我这个只能卖
我这个最低只能卖100
你你这个只能要100
只能卖100
最低只能卖100
然后你说嗯不行
最低8080我要
然后你俩谈崩了
你就转身就走了
这代表什么
这代表然后你你转身走了
待会你又回来说哎 100卖吗
100可以卖
这个时候他不想卖你了
为什么为什么这代表什么
就你走了你走了之后
讲价讲崩了之后你又回来
这代表什么
这代表你
是需要这个东西的
你是缺这个东西的
只是你在无底线的讲价
这个时候我是一个聪明的商家
120150 一分都不能少
要不要不要就滚蛋
好吗这个时候你肯定会买
因为你转了一圈回来了
你发现诶
原来我还是需要这个东西
这个时候需求感就出来了好吗
这个时候需求感就出来了
所以说挽回他就是你讲价不成功
然后又吃一个回头草
你肯定会被别人
你肯定会被别人讲价
就只要你去做挽回
你肯定会被女人讲价
懂不懂
那如果说你回来讲价你肯
你她给的价格你又不满意
你又只能懂吗
你只能求她
所以说一定要揣着一个
为什么要去做高价值挽回
也就是你要去做这样一个东西
你在其他其他地方
你在其他地方看了一个更好的价格
他可能90多也要卖
90也要卖
但是你是你是因为
先答应了这个商家
然后才回来买他这个懂吗
你要有一个好的理由
好的借口
这就是我们的高价值挽回诶
我价值很高我现在
我我我我健身有了成果
我又有了更好的生意
我又有了更好的工作
我现在生活过得很好
但是我还是愿意选择你
愿意还是愿意跟你聊天
懂吗你要给女生你要给
你如果说要做一个高价值挽回
你要去做挽回
你一定要给女生
传达出这样一个信息
就是我现在过得非常不错
但是我还是愿意选择你
这是因为我们之前的感情
我们之前的一些经历
我很在乎
懂吗前提是你生活过得很好
其次是不舔
没有需求感去跟她聊这样的东西
两者缺一不可
你的展示面
你的朋友圈
你整个人最近三个月的一个状态
要非常的好
非常的牛逼
非常的ok
这是价值
然后跟他聊
我们还要技术层面的东西不舔
不骄不躁
不卑不亢去聊
这样才能挽回
懂吗这是一个很复杂的板块
而且成功率也不敢保证知道吗
为什么要去挽回
哎我们说到一个重点
挽回就是要被别人讲价
这是我不喜欢去挽回的一个原因
你你不就
我说难听一点兄弟不
你不就找不到这么
这么一个胸大屁股翘的
所以说你还你还回去
你还回去去挽回她
你不就为什么一个人会去挽回
不就是因为他资源少嘛对不对
女人都知道
这个被你挽回的这个女人她都知道
不你不
你这个屌丝不就资源少嘛
你找了半天你都没女的嘛
你又来找我嘛
她肯定不想自己那么廉价呀
绝对不可能答应你的
所以说你要表达出来的
高价值我这么高的价值了
我还愿意再回来找你
你没有这一套逻辑
你是行不通的
你是走不通的
你有了这一套逻辑
你都还可能有失败率
懂吗不要去挽回
就他是太太亏损
他很亏损你这个人的气血知道吗
去挽回他会把你这个人的运气
你这个人的自信心
你这个人的自我价值认可给剥夺掉
懂吗他会把你这个人给毁了的
所以说我不建议你去挽回
你去获得更多的资源不一样的吗
对吧你获得更多的资源
我就不信对吧
天涯何处无芳草是吧
挽回记
给我记住这个概念
只要去挽回
就要被别人讲价
讲价就代表就代表着你要当狗
讲价就代表着你要给他当狗
而且当狗不一定有有有骨头赏你的
当狗不一定有骨头赏你的
只是有可能有可能你当狗
可能有可能会赏你一根骨头
只是可能
何必呢兄弟这对
我知道你是很想要去得到她
很想要拥有她的肉体
很想要拥有她的灵魂
但是他对你未来的影响
他对你这个人内核的影响
是非常是非常巨大的
是非常可怕的
你不要忽略了这个东西
这个东西可能会让你一蹶不振的
懂吗你会你会在这个女人身上
浪费5年10年甚至一辈子
因为你被她操控了
你被她死死干住
你被她死死操控了懂吗
你被她锁住了
你被她挂住了
怎么你这个人被她挂一辈子划算吗
兄弟们划算吗
你是一个男人啊
你不是一个bitch
呃我们看一下抖音这个兄弟
他说为什么每次跟女生聊力竭了
说明你菜呗
就你你问我的问题太过于宽泛了
太过于范围太大了
范围太大了
你你问我为什么
每次跟女生聊力竭了
因为你你的技术太菜了
我只能回答你这样
一个概念性的一个答案
所以所以你要问我
具体性的一个东西
女人持续发了什么东西
或者说你又持续回了什么东西
或者说他不跟你出来
或者说他哎
跟你扯什扯什么乱七八糟的
就是不跟你聊感情
就是不跟你聊关系方面的问题
什么原因力竭了
不要给我来一句
为什么跟女生每次聊聊力竭了fuck
我们看一下嗯抖音这个兄弟说
杰哥能给一点预约拉吸引
做肢体接触的小技巧吗
我告诉你
看过我的体系吗
这个未测拥有
这个兄弟
你看过我的体系吗
Jackson flow
有看过我的体系吗
有看过真实流的体系吗
我觉得这里有一些你的师兄哈
跟你一起学的
他都能回答你这个问题
有兄弟有兄弟替他回答这个问题吗
就是他问的问题是杰哥能给点
一约拉吸引做肢体接触的小技巧吗
他觉得拉吸引需要靠肢体接触
他觉得拉吸引是靠肢体接触
升级关系是需要肢体接触他觉得
很多东西可以去做吸引
很多东西可以做吸引
你能你能引起他的情绪波动
你能引起他的情绪波动就有吸引
怎么你现在讲了一个很
无很无厘头的笑话
你说哎我那天跟一个女生约会
啊我当当着她的面抠鼻屎
她说哎你怎么这么恶心
要抠鼻屎
我说你不抠鼻屎吗啊
你每天在在家里就抠脚趾缝抠鼻屎
你抠吗那个女生就哈哈大笑
啊我要抠啊
懂吗你讲了这样一个笑话
他都会有吸引
吸引是很多东西都可以去做
你你你你你讲一个叙事啊
你说我小时候我小时候我带了嗯我
从我我从我爸我从我爸的床底下
我从我爸的床底
那个时候我那个时候我才读四年级
那个时候我才读四年级
我从我爸床底下翻了一堆
翻了翻了一堆光碟
翻了一堆什么什么叉叉光碟出来
就是看那种就是那种
很很黄的那种光碟
把它翻出来
然后放进我的书包里面
然后我带带到学校去给同学看
结果被学习委员
结果被学习委员举报了
然后被老师被老师请了家长
我讲这样一个叙事
女生也能获得情绪
她也会产生吸引
啊为什么你还有这样的一些行为
你是一个很调皮的小孩吗
啊你是一个有性
你为什么那么小就开始看片了
为什么那么小就接触那些东西了
难道你是一个难道你是
一个很会玩的男生吗
她的脑子里会想
知道吗而这个时候吸引就来了
拉吸引不是去靠肢体触碰
肢体触碰是你在做那
件事情去调情用的把
不是那不是不是那个no way
不是不是肢体触碰
不是肢体触碰
升级关系
获得吸引
不是肢体触碰
不要去做肢体触碰
每天都在讲
每天每天everyday
每天的直播
每天的live都在讲
不要去肢体触碰
给我记住
真实流第一条
真实流解读法则
第一条就是不要去碰女人
不要在外面去碰女人好吧
对BN这个兄弟说的没错
m m 4这个兄弟说的没错
假皮肢体接触尽量私密空间去做
它是在某些场合是拿来什么TQ用的
TQ什么叫TKTQ调什么
调什么用的
我们注意一下用词
兄弟们我们注意一下用词
因为其实国内的平台审核很严
你如果说如果说我在Youtube
在油管去进行直播
那么我可以讲得很奔放
讲给你讲得清清楚楚
私密空间给你讲得清清楚楚
各种各种各种18禁给
你讲得清清楚楚
但是这里是在中国
这里是在国内
不可以好吧大妹
咱们什么什么东西能产生吸引
兄弟们很简单
你看我的直播
我怎么样抢
我怎么样去去讲述一件东西
我在说什么话
我在做什么动作
这些东西都叫吸引力懂不懂
这些东西都叫吸引力
你不是因为你不是因为
我对你进行肢体升级
我也没有对你进行肢体触碰
但是照样可以干住你
懂吗这个东西叫做吸引
吸引力吸引attraction
好吧
吸引力attraction
这个东西就叫做吸引
你的言行举止
你这个人的精神内核
不是因为我有多帅
不是因为我有多骚好吗
不是因为我在肢体升级里
对不对不照样能吸引你吗
所以说你觉得吸引力是所谓的
肢体触碰或者肢体升级在做吗
no way不是好吧
一定是你这个人的言行举止
你整个人的构成
你这个人的人设
肢体不代表进度对肢体不
你能碰到他的你能碰到
他的上半身某些部位
不代表你可以跟他
懂吗你可以跟他
也不不代表你可以跟他鼓掌
他不是就很多人
我们前几天才讲过这个东西
很多人很多小白
很多新手
很多国男
他们的脑子里
他们的脑子里想的就是诶
我可以做到第一步了
我可以摸她的摸她的哪些地方了
我下一步又可以摸她的哪些地方
下一下一步我可以亲她哪些地方
下一步我可以伸到某些地方
下一步我可以插到某些地方
不是这样的
不是他妈进度条
肢体触碰不是进度条
真的你们会把自己害死的
如果你们这么想
你们会把自己害死的
肢体触碰不是进度条的好吧
呃我们看一下b站这个兄弟说
他说杰哥可以讲解一下今天
内部群女生说见面介意有纹身
为什么要直面吗
他的我们
他的直面
我我要你直面的是他的那句话
是他那句话
如果介意就如果介意就不见了
这是证明这个女人
我可以我可以以我的阅历
以我的情感经验
以我的教学经验
我可以瞬间判断出这个女人
他非常的敏感
这个人他非常的敏感
甚至于他在之前被
很多男生放过鸽子
被很多男生水过
可能见过面说他这个点很多次
懂吗所以你必须要直面这个问题
这个问题是他的心魔
这个问题是他的心魔知道吗
是他的执念
你必须要去解决
你不解决这个问题出来
他就会因为这个问题跟你搞事
你就搞不定
所以说我们必须要直面
懂了吗必须要去直面
而你直接去舔她
你所谓的友好和宽容很假为什么
因为陌生人
因为别人不会关心
不会平白无故关心你
如果说平白无故关心你
如果说一个男人
平白无故的关心一个正妹
或说一个女人
那一定是
就傻子连小孩都知道为什么她要
没有缘故的去关心一个女人
因为他想搞定她
因为他想搞她
好吧
连小孩都知道
连男人都知道
为什么你觉得一个女人
她不知道你想干什么
你的友好是因为什么
给我把那句经典的话打出来
内部群的兄弟们
油好你的油好
那句话叫什么
你的油好
这里我直播间不能说啊
有记得的兄弟们
有记得的兄弟们可以打出来
你的油好
一个友好的男人
你是一个友好的男人
friendly friendly boy friendly man
有有有个词叫什么有个词叫什么
我觉得有个词非常的
经典有个词非常的经典
friendly dog friendly dog这个非常的经典
对吧中文叫做什么好朋狗好朋狗
我觉得我觉得拿友好
当然这里不是在说理啊兄弟
因为我看过很多的白骑士
我看过很多的白骑士
这里完全不是在说理
因为你知道啊ok去反驳去什么
我看这里主要是指白骑士
很多的白骑士很多为
很多以友好的
很多很多人甚至他去当gay
他假装gay
他假装自己是自己是gay为了去
鼓掌为了去跟这个女人鼓掌
他假装自己是个gay
然后他很友好
他非常的友好
我称这一这一类人就叫什么
好朋狗好朋狗好朋狗
三个字好朋狗
friendly dog
什么
他们不应该叫白骑士
他们不是为了
为什么他们不不应该叫白骑士
因为骑士是守护公主的
骑士是他妈的守护公主的
而这些人不是想守护公主
他们只想吃掉公主
他们只想干掉公主
他们只想sleep好吧
他们只想睡
所以他们不是白骑士
他们不是白骑士
他们只是friendly dog
所以他们不应该叫白骑士好吧
不应该叫白骑士
绝对不能叫白骑士
我觉得侮辱了骑士这个词
侮辱了骑士这个词
太逗了好朋狗
呃这个词太好笑了
呃呃我们看一下b站这个兄弟XO
他说杰哥
请问怎么说话发声
给别人稳定的感觉
呃你就像我现在这个
我现在这个说话的这个音域
差不多是在呃中低音没有
这个没有很低音
这没有很低音
可能在第第二第三个八度
没有很低音
就中音是什么
中音是什么
我现在我现在的
说话这个声音是中音
我现在我情绪激昂的时候
你不能一直的呃那么低
你比如说比如说像某克一样
像什么冥想流一样
某克他说话就是一直在那个低音域
我我现现在要跟你玩一个游戏
赢了的话我会得到一个吻
那么就是他的声音一直在这个程度
你不能一直低
你一直低你就不叫稳定
你你一直低你就不这
不叫稳定
你会你会给人很奇怪的一种感觉
你会给人很奇怪的一种感觉
啊比如说我们之前有
嗯嗯油管上油管上比如说
呃比如说某大师某大师柯老师
他就是一直那种声音
声声音比较那种一直一条线的那种
能产生一定的神秘感
但是久了会审美疲劳会很困
所以说最好的方式
不是你一直的去稳定
给我记住
不是你一直的去稳定好吧
这样会让人想睡觉
如果说我这
如果说我这样直播
会让你们很想睡觉
你们可以把它当成一个ASMR来听
当成一个助眠来听a ASMR
懂吗
但是我们是一个科普类
一个认知类
一个技术类
一个情感类的直播
我们需要有情绪的结合
你跟女生的时候
如果说你遇到了
如果说你遇到了一个
本身就对你吸引力
就觉你的吸引力就对
她很强烈的一个女生那么
你可以这样
你可以一直这样说
他是有好处的他是一
让你觉得你这个人
非常所谓的稳定的
你遇到天窗
你可以这样去操作
但如果说你遇到了黄单
你遇到了一些窗口没那么大的
你用这样的方式去
你会死掉的
你会死无葬身之地好吗
所以说你需要有结合
情绪的声音以及状态
你在低沉的时候
你说话就应该是现在比较稳定的
你在情绪高昂的时候
那么你需要很高的一个肢体配合
加你的加你的音色
加你的状态
他要没有任何的违和感
这才是表达能力的终极体现所以说
你的浮躁
或者说你的一些音调高
它不是你的缺点知道吗
这个兄弟
各位兄弟们
你们的声音声线比较高
它不是你的缺点
只是他用错了场合
所以说在某些时候你用一下低音域
在某些时候你用
一下高的音域是ok的
是ok的这样全面一点
不要专门的去压那种很低
我想跟你玩一个游戏
赢了的话
我会获得一个快速的吻
不要去不要去这样好吧
节目效果有了没有
兄弟们节目效果有了没有
兄弟们这次直播有没有节目效果
有没有那种戏剧的
有没有那种戏剧的效果
好我们先连一个麦啊
鲍尔不是要连麦吗
如果说你开两个的话
那可能有回音
你开这个你开
可能你开了两个平台的
就有回音
正常应该是没有的
鲍尔不是要连麦吗
还需要连吗
不连我连别人了
我们先等一下吧他吧
然后看一下问题
嗯
这个抖音这个兄弟
这个未测拥有
他说不是预约不踢的话
建议最好能case吗
不然后续要重新积累进度
如果说你预约不推导的话
能case的话
是必须要case的
这个在我们前面的直播讲过
必须得case
对你这一点是没
这一点是没错的
因为二约如果说你没有达到
你一约不TD
你没达到一定的进度的话
你二约又要重新去积累
这个吸这个吸引吸引进度条
所以说呃如果说你不TD的话
也是需要去做一个
比较高度的肢体接触的
好他现在没连麦
那我就先连你吧好吧
那就先连你吧
喂杰哥
请问能听到吗
稍等我开一下声音
啊
现在能听得清吗
嗯哼
好我想问杰哥一个问题就是呃
关于一约的
我昨天和一个女生进行了一约
然后她是我搭讪认识的
嗯
在约会当中嗯
她有说自己是一个很反差的女生
就是看外表比较会
但其实内心非常的传统
然后我不不在
不经意间和他聊到了插话题
然后当时他说他是一个只能
接受婚后才能进行插行为的人
嗯
然后我当时就跟进
了一个柏拉图框架
我说就是
那个其实
但是其实假意的跟进
因为他后面又跟我
battle回到了这个话题
就是我后面问他
那你是x和i分开的人吗
他说他是的
他说就是如果他真的深爱一个人
他可以就是什么都做但是
可以为了她把叉放到结婚之后
这你你你先
你他现在
他说的意思不是
就是叉和爱分开啊
他说的是连在一起的呀
他这然后他这样的一个意思
就是他说这一段
他刚才说
他可能理解错你的意思
对然后我又和他讲说
如如如如果说呃我
反正是做不到这一点
就是如果我很深爱一个人
我肯定会自然而然想和他亲近
那你你这不就是把需求感暴露了吗
这个时候已经不是
价值观价值观的那
这是你在这个时候他
会识别到你的需求感
你说你你去说
他说了刚刚说了
他说他很
哪怕很爱
他他也会结婚
什么之后之后什么
你又去跟了这个东西
那其实就把你的需求感暴露了
哦反正就我感觉这里有
一点点不太会操作
然后当时约会的时候
她就是说我有很多价
价值观给她带来了一些冲击
她说就好像认知洗礼一样
嗯
就是他他你他
就是如果说你识别到他了
是一个外表说很骚
很很浪的人
这个东西就没错
他是一个闷骚对不对
他是一个闷骚的人
这是肯定的
嗯对不对
对我有点出他这一点
我说你就赞同他
那你就赞同他的这个框架就行了嘛
你不需要在这个时候去
讲讲出你自己想要的
因为在这个时候讲
在这个时候
你可以在之前讲出
他没有讲出
他没有讲出他必须要婚后什么什么
的这样的一个叙事的时候
你可以去讲出你自己
的这样的一个价值观
但是在这个节点
他讲出了他婚后必须什么什么
你再讲出你自己的
那其实就坐实了你的一个需求感
懂我意思吧
确实感觉有一点
时候在这个时候你至少是不能讲的
你可以如果说他讲出来这个
你不是很赞同
你说嗯挺不错的
我觉得你的你的观念
呃我不能说很赞赞同
但是我觉
但是我绝对不反对
懂吗你就打个哈哈过去就行了
哦
他会因为情绪跟你到达一定的浓度
会跟你发生TD
对确确实杰哥
我不应该去从逻辑和他battle
不要尝试去讲理
特别是他已经给出了
他如果说是一个模棱两可的
嗯可以去跟他尝试用
三个价值拍battle一下
讲三个价值去battle一下
但是他这个底色是非常的鲜明的
就是他是白的
而你说的东西是黑的
你很难去浸染他
在这个时候
进行逻辑上的battle是
很难去浸染他的
所以说你就打个哈哈就行嗯
我觉得还不错
嗯嗯嗯你这样女生你这样
的女生其实蛮多的
哦好的杰哥
对就我碰到这种感觉很
传统的女生有一点没招
现在
其实不会其实不会
只是他跟你现在
他的面具没揭下来
你只需要顺着他去走就行了
那么到了私密空间
你该做做什么懂吗
你该调就调
他会就是他的意志力
他的意志力是战胜不了他的身体的
你要告我告诉你
人这人的意志力是很脆弱的
他战胜不了他身体的反应的
我们好的杰哥这一块本能
来抓人人人性兽性动物性
感谢杰哥
嗯
那我先下麦了
让鲍尔兄提问
好
啊那大家可以总结出刚来
刚才有什么样的一个干货
还是我们的一个还是我们的
一个之前讲过的一个干货叫什么
拖字诀
非常的牛逼
我觉得这是我自己人生贯彻的
懂吗
我我人生里面贯彻的一个最大的
一个绝招拖字诀
好我们下一个连麦开始
喂
听不到听不到
有人吗
what's up guy
刚来怎么就托自觉了呃
之前的前面几期
直播有讲过这个东西
然后现在我们又
接着讲了这个托自觉
然后b站也有回放
后面可以后面可以回看一下好吧
后面可以回看一下
稍等我去拿一个充电宝啊
拿这个拿一个充电宝
有一个手机没电了
好continue it
刚为什么连不上麦
有什么问题吗
啊我们接着连麦
喂
喂喂喂还是听不到还是听不到
你插了耳机吗
不要插耳机
不要去连耳机
不要去连什么麦克风之类的
为什为什么会听不到
你看一下你这里开开麦了吗
你看一下你自己的呃抖音那里设置
或者权限之类的
啊实在不行用视频号吧
也可以用视频号
实在不行用视频号吧
我们先回答其他兄弟的一个问题
你先下麦吧
杰哥为什么要把头发夹起来
嗯这个天气太热了吧
天气太热了
搭着头发他很长就搭
头发会搭到这里
眼睛眼睛会遮住
然后很热
很不舒服
喂
喂喂杰哥听得到吗
哦能听到
哎好嘞好嘞
呃就是我想问几个问题吧
嗯
就是首先就是今
就是今天我在群里就是就
发了一下我那个展示面
感觉是问题是比较大的
就是主要是想在这
方面想去请教一下你
我操这有点干货啊
啊啊
啊就是首先就是想去问一下
就是呃你们平时展示面
这个地点是怎么选择的
嗯
我只能给你大概的
因为我如果说直接给到那个
其实就是我们的一些商业机密了
好吧
啊懂的懂的懂的
给你大一个大概的
就是你挑什么文创社区就ok了
啊挑文创社区是吧
对挑一些文创社区就行了
你在小红书上
你搜什么打卡出片都ok
这个其实看你自己审美啊
看你自己审美
地点很好啊
行就是就是要有一点艺术性的那种
对吧
就其实说实话
你找一个好看的街道
它也是ok的
就不用非要说什么很有艺术气它它
这个还是看你自己审美
就真的你在街道上
你看很多那种很多
那种几几十万点赞的
懂吗几十万点赞的
抖音几十万点赞的
嗯
或者说一些淘宝模特
他们真的就在一个街道
去架好一个架好一个机器去拍
啊好的好的好的
呃然后再就是这个
就是展示面里面需要展示的价值
您是您可以举几个例子吧
首先是我们的一个下线管理嘛
嗯
你你我看了你的展示面
下限管理做的非常的差对吧
杠可也指出来了
嗯
下限管理是我们的
一个展示面体系里面
我们的一个真实流
体系里面很重要的
关于展示面的很重要的一个点
你解决下线管理
这个展示面就不会差
你放了七八张好
七八张六七张对吧
呃就6
5张吧就5张
我觉得你放3张都比你放放5张好
或者说你实在少放两张
都比你现在效果要好一些
懂吗不能去
不能去图放的多
不能去给他
为了放满而去把一些
垃圾的东西给他塞上去
你知道吗
有一有句话叫什么
一颗耗一颗耗子屎就打乱一锅汤
这就是下线管理的
一个绝佳的一个体现懂吗
下线管理要做好
然后你的
你的我
你要展示的
如果说你想展示
我们阶级肯定是要去展示的阶级
如果说你想把更高质量的妹子
你的阶级是要去展示的
阶级不是代表你去哪里哪里哪里玩
把九宫格全部塞满
我告诉你
那些朋友圈里面
置顶里面塞了塞了10个
加了10个20个朋友圈
里面每个都是九宫格塞满的
那种人他补
他的资源不会很好
怎么
他的资源这个我知道
就他他的资源可能会很会很多
但全部是些low逼
全部是些low逼
你你要你你有一个什么
你有一个南极去玩的一个南极游轮
去南极去玩的一个展示面
一个展示面就足够秒杀
那些所有的什么旅游的
就他得精
啊就这方面要多思考一下懂的
对你要把自己弄得精精英一点
而不是说去
我我们这里展示面还是要
玩一个什么叫脱颖而出
脱颖而出
就是你要跟其他人的展示面不同的
我嗯
之前哈我们不是有做过一些节目
汉克不是有做过一些节目吗就是他
他约他跟他那个他跟他
那个py去拍了一个节目
然后那个py说这
那他们不是在评价
谁谁谁的展示面嘛对吧
有那一期
有没有印象
嗯
呃
嗯我知道
他在评价谁谁谁的一个展示面
然后那个女的
就是那个探肯嘉宾
她说这个这个展示面的
这个人是一个德痴哥
你们乍一听
还以为这个女的在夸这个男的诶
他他是德痴哥
那我应该要向这个德痴哥学习
学习他的展示面
你你你们是不是这样的想的
啊没有
就感觉他是觉得这个男的
在故意去搞这些东西钓鱼
应该是这种想法
他的意思是这个男的很臭很脏
而且很low
啊懂吗
是
所以说你要做的是跟那些人区分开
我放照片
我跟你说
这直接就是干货了
这直接他妈就是干货
我在我的朋友圈放照片
不会一次发的照片不会超过两张
更多的80%的是放一张
我拍一个场景
我我拍一个场景
我拍一套穿搭
或者说拍一个
展示一个东西
我可能会拍20张 30张
但是我不管
这30张里面有10张好看的
有5张好看的
我都不管
我只要一张
其他全部丢掉
啊就是挑一张最好的
对就我只要一张
其他全部丢掉
了解了
这种我告诉你这个原理叫什么
米其林摆盘
听懂了吧
懂了
就你你你去一个你去一个馆子
你去一个苍蝇馆子
一盘全是满的全是肉全是菜
快点
ok是很好吃但是
你你会把它拍去发朋友圈吗
绝对不会
因为它
是是是会很臃肿看着
因为它它太多了
多就是烂
多就是廉价
懂吗太油腻太多了
所以说你需要一个米其林的摆盘
一个一个脸那么大的一个盘子
一个陶瓷盘子
放中间放那么一块
就放那么一块
这就是高级感
哇
确实确实确实还真是
所以以后你的朋友圈你的朋友圈
下线管理做好
然后把米其林把米其林法则
米其林摆盘法则给我做好
等我两分钟呗
其他审其他审美的那些
你短期之内搞不定
而且那个不是
一句话两句话能说清楚
它而且它是实操的动作
哪怕我给你干货
我说这个构图怎么构
那个角度怎么拍
光怎么来的
这些东西你能理解吗
你理解不了对不对
所以说那些东专业性
的东西我们不去说
我们把概念搞清楚
就是你的就是你的下线管理
下线管理
还有什么
呃就是您刚刚说的一些
就是那种具体啊构图啊
光这些实际上我是平时有
是有所了解一些吧
就是我现在是
呃因为我跟我一个朋友都还是蛮
本身就是都还喜欢拍一些
平时就是大大致有所了解就是
就是我我现在有个观点
不知道您赞不赞同啊
就是我觉得就是一般一般
情况下感觉就是那种呃纯拍
正脸感觉应该是比较少的吧
就是除非你是颜值特别高的那种
纯拍正脸
这里给了一个干货
这里给了一个干货嗯
大家都记一下
就是纯拍正脸不能第三方拍摄
不能第三方拍摄
对他只能自拍
哦
OK我记一下
诶但是如果你只拍正脸自拍的话
它不是那个镜头它会
畸变得特别厉害吗这样子
不会啊你开两倍就行了
哦哦对对对
确实确实
是的是的
确实呃
然后一点的话就是就是在
就是呃我看我看就是就是
我看那个呃斌哥他的一些
就是他发朋友圈里面那些展示面嘛
我看好多都是呃就基本上
都是在那个室内里面拍的
就是在室室外是不是
就只有是那种可能
呃街道上啊
或者是说那种地方
就是在那种
比方说在那种纯就
比方说在那种山里面
那种比较自然风光那种
是不是比较
那种需要比较独特
一点的地方才能去
街道
啊这个东西如果说要严格来讲的话
都可以拍
看你自己的构图和审美
啊行
就是他不是说非要
有一个特定的地点
OK
呃然后然后就是那个
就是关于这个衣服的
这个版型的这个选择
就是我就我就问个具体一点
就是比方说夏天这种
这个t恤是不是尽量要
选那种有垫肩的呀
或者说宽松一点那种
显得你肩可能宽一点这样
你拍照不用啊
啊就拍照不需要管这些是吧
拍照我再我再给你们他妈一个干货
拍照不要去穿垫肩和增高鞋
收到OK
这个我没有我没有
我是没有的
这是别人别人这样跟我说的
很多傻缺很多傻缺还以为
诶我拍照我要把自己的
呃肩
垫肩还有什么增高鞋全给穿上
但实际上你你拍出来了
人家知道你穿那个呀
而且非常的奇怪
因为你的站姿和你的坐姿
它会垫起来
非常一大一坨
你拍出来反而不好看
懂吗你有你有修图啊
你可以修图啊
你可以p图啊
你为什么要去垫肩呢你
懂吗你修图比电电更自然
懂懂懂懂懂懂懂懂懂懂懂
对
ok
然后再就是这个摄影风格这个问题
就是我看
就是我看那个
就是就是我我现在观察
的就是只能就是只能看
就是呃各个导师的朋友圈嘛
就我看那个
汉汉克斯导师那个朋友圈
就是他发放出来一些那种样片嘛
就是
呃有那个逼导的
还有那个斌哥的
然后就是看到就是
他们两个我看就是
好像就是风格都是打造是那种
就相当于是一个皮衣
都是穿一个皮衣
然后比较man的那种形象就是我
但是我看杰哥你好像就是
你的那个
就是我看你那个样片是比较的
就是精英化
商业精英化那种
就是关于这个风
这个展示面的这个人设
打造是怎么选择这种
呃没有
这个是我只我展
我展示的是我作为公司的主理人
是作为leader的一个
角色去放放商业的
我没有去把我自己的
一些生活化的东西放出来
哦对的
就是展示的东西不一样
我自己在我自己朋友圈没有一没有
我自己在我自己的撩妹这个号里
的朋友圈没有一张是这种商务的
全是那种就可能少年感什么呃
那种呃人夫啊什么那些都有
啊行
呃然后再就是就是为什么
就是呃就是你们把那个像
就是像斌哥
然后像b导他们就设置是
都是那种相当于像像教父里面那种
就是穿个西装那种
那种风格
就是这个是有有什么思路吗
就是设计成这样子的
那那是对
那是对于商业的business这一块
不是说你拿去撩妹的
哦这样子
懂了懂了
对你不要把这个拿去
这样的图拿去撩妹好吧
啊懂了
然后就是我现在在网上看到一个观
一种观点
就是说说说展示面
就是说像
说什么要
就是生活化
就是您怎么看待这个观
就是我看现在很多
号都是打这个观点
然后起号的那种
这个是我觉得就是
因为生活
就打个比方
他们就他们就要求你
就是比方说发四张图
有一张是你自己
然后另外三张就是全是要去那种
比方说就是单纯的一杯咖啡啊
或者说那种什么之类的
就是您怎么看待这种这种方式
嗯其实不太建议
啊行
因为我说一下原原理哈
就是如果说你放了什么一杯咖啡
或者说一个风景那之类的
很容易就是被人以为你是盗图
所以说不管是咖啡什么的
里面也要有你
嗯这就是生活
他们说比方说
他们要发四宫格
就是就四张图中有一张是你
然后其他三张必须
是跟你的生活相关
就这种意思
就他们互相抄来抄去吧
就是我反正我不我不去看这些东西
我按我自己的实战经验来
什么东西好用我就用什么
ok OK OK行
那我肯定相信杰哥的这个经验
嗯
呃然后再最后最后一个问题就是
就是有关
就是我现在就是增肌嘛
我现在在增肌嘛
然后就是因为我是那种
就是我是有183 但是我
整体的整体的体重不知道
为什么就一直在75千克左右
就一直上不去
就是我天天都在
我天天都在健身
然后饮食控制的也还行
就是每天每天就是就是
蛋白质啊什么之类的
然后鱼油也吃
还有一些补剂也吃
但是不知道为什么
这个体重一直上不去
就是关于增肌这方面
你有没有什么经验这种
碳水吃少了
嗯
啊就是
但是这个之前不是说就是
之前SIM SIM还在群里面
他不是说就是要尽量
去戒掉这个米饭吗
还是说怎么样
他那说的是减脂的东西啊
增我告诉你
我告诉你一个点
从营营营营从营养学方面来讲
增肌和减脂是不能同时进行的
就是你的减脂有
多少你的减脂有多少
你的增肌就会被拉下多少
你的增肌有多少你的
减脂就会被拉下多少
原来如此
你的肌糖原太少了
你肯定长得慢
你从现在开始你要出你要来
你要脏一点脏增肌
炫碳炫多一点
等到足够大了
练个一年了
那个时候再去刷脂
但是肯定在这段时间你
的撩妹或者什么那些
什么都会有问题
哦行行行OK那我先
我感觉我还是需要先增一增重
因为我感觉我现在就是有一点就是
看上去有一点瘦了
就是我我肩是
我比例实际上还行
我肩是比较宽的那种就线下
然后但是看起来是比较瘦的
行就到这里吧
我们其他还有兄弟要
OK OK
好谢谢杰哥
谢谢杰哥
就是就这么多
就这么多
好
ok那我先挂
呃
其他呃视频号上连麦的这两个兄弟
你是我们的内部学员才可以连麦
如果说你是我们的内部学员
会员群里面的
你可以发一下连麦的申请
说说一下你在这个
视频号以及你在这个me
social media上面的一个名字好吧
你说一下名字
然后我们开始接麦
看视频好还是电视的回放啊
嗯b站有回放的
b站有回放好吧
好我们接着回答一下
抖音的兄弟们提问
我们抓紧时间
因为时间不多了
还以为是种做发型的方式
对现在也有这种做发型的方式啊
它同时有简练
然后又同时
还可以还好看吧兄弟们
这发型还可以吧
这整的还还能行吧
我还没有去
在头上打东西
这头上一点东西没打
我再打点东西把它打理一下
造型会更好看
弄一点什么这种懂吗
弄一点那种头发下来
或者做一下造型
会非常好看
我建议大家去学一下我这个发型啊
不要再他妈什么碎盖了油头了
不要再搞那些了
告诉你们真正的干货
跟随时代的版本好吧
跟随时代的版本
真正的干货
就我的发型都是干货
告诉你我的发型都是干货
我的发型就是attraction
歌可以分享吗
你要歌单干嘛
兄弟你要歌歌单干嘛
你先告诉我你歌单的用途
我才好推荐给你
生发攻略生发攻略我
前两天不是讲了吗
生发攻略我前两天就讲了
如果说你有你有脱发
如果说你有发际线发际线后移
去做去把你的后面的头发给他植发
植到前面去
花个几千
花个几千上万
植到植到前面去
然后让他长一段时间
吃什么药吃什么药
吃非那雄胺
把你自己的雄激素降一下
他就能一直维持
你实在不想吃药了
等你娶到老婆
等你等你玩够了再说吧对吧
等你玩够了再说吧
你不能既要又要吧哎
我又不想吃药哎
我又想又想把自己整的好看
那我告诉你不可能
然后我们看一下然后我们看一下
然后我看一下抖音这个兄弟提的问
然后杰哥刚刚搭讪一组双人组
我对闺蜜说认识你朋友
闺蜜同意了
目标走了
是怎么回事
这个点讲过
第一期直播里面讲过这个
好像是给这个lives John去复盘的时候
这个东西讲过去听第一期直播
去去听我的抖音第一期直播回放
在b站在b站真实社交Jason
搜索真实社交Jason可以
看到我们的第一期回放
你就知道怎么去解决
那里说了一个具体的方法的好吧
是我们线下的一个付费的技巧
给到给到他的
你可以去重复听一下
学习一下
那我们跟接着回答哈
兄弟们不要再提新的问题了
最后回答几个问题我们就下播了
呃回答快一点
然后Livis join这个兄弟说杰哥
如果说只想放两张
想突出风景
要入镜觉得刻意怎么办
嗯
就是你这个风景
你可以拍横图
如果说你想突出风景
你想突出风景
你拍16:9 或者说1016比9的一个横图
就能又能突突出风景
又想入镜好吧
这个就不刻意
不要放一个竖图
然后人在那里
那样风景突出不了
我们接着回答
吴越这个兄弟说
杰哥如何知道自己的
经验方法是正确的
以及发现错误之后如何
找到正确的方法思路
呃付费找导师
付费找有经验的人
懂吗不会走错路
你靠你自己摸要花很多年
如果说你的时间成本不够
你你的钱
你的资金刚好充足
那么你这个方法
如果说你资金也不充足时间
时间很充足
那么你自学
但是他走花的时间就更多好吧
就只能说你你可以你
可以天天来找我们答疑
天天来去解决你的问题
细节性的问题细节性的问题
这样你才能学习的更快
这是给到你们的一个福利
免费的一个白嫖的福利好吧
我们看一下鹌鹑蛋这兄弟说
杰哥搭讪女生不停一直走怎么办
我要跟多久
截停呀截停呀
截停啊谁让你跟的
谁让你跟
截停知道吗
一定要去做截停
搭讪一定要做截停
不做截停
你的框架是弱的
他不会搭
他不会对你产生吸引的
一定要去做截停好吧
OK
那么今天我们的答疑时间就到这里
直播时间就到这里
明天我们同一时间9点钟
再给大家继续进行直播
进行连麦解决大家的一个问题
给大家更多的一个干货
this is Jackson flow see you fucking next time
最后一句话
大家说一下
吃饭父母教
知识老师教
想脱单找谁
兄弟们给你们5秒钟时间打文字
吃饭父母教
知识老师教
想脱单找谁
OK结束
下期再见
New fans,
Click the like button in the upper left corner.
We are professional here.
about your emotions,
about how to get female resources,
about how to date,
how to date a girl,
how to approach a girl,
emotional channel, okay?
If you haven't joined my
brothers who haven't joined my fan club,
Light up the fan light card.
Pay one cent to light up the fan light board.
and become my old fan.
and then come to learn with me every day.
and you can get emotional freedom earlier, okay?
Brothers who come in, click the like button in the upper left.
Click the like button in the upper left corner.
Click the like button.
Please like it first.
Like it first.
Brothers, like it first.
If you haven't joined my fan club yet,
spend one cent to light up our fan light card.
Become an old fan as soon as possible, okay?
Brothers who come in, click the like button in the upper left.
Like, like, like, like, like.
We will start answering questions later.
Uh, you can connect to the mic.
Let's connect later.
Because there aren't many people now.
Wait a few minutes.
a few minutes later,
or ten minutes later.
We can start the live chat at nine ten.
We'll start the live chat at nine ten.
This bro from Bilibili,
Let's wait for other fans.
Wait for other fans.
New friends who just joined us,
Click the like button in the upper left corner.
Click the little heart.
Like it first when you come in.
Be polite.
Be a polite free rider, okay?
Be a polite free rider.
If you haven't joined my fan club yet,
spend one yuan to light up the fan light card,
and then join my fan club.
Become an old fan earlier.
and then learn with me every day.
and make progress with me.
Like it first.
Like it first, okay?
New fans who come in,
New fans, please like it first.
The little heart in the upper left corner.
Click the like button.
Please like it.
Brothers who haven't joined my fan club yet,
Spend one cent to light up the fan light card.
Join my fan club as soon as possible.
and then learn with me every day.
grow up with me,
and make progress with me.
Don't you want to improve?
It's okay to watch my live stream one hundred times.
Great, you've done it a hundred times.
That's great.
Uh, if you want to connect with me, it's on TikTok.
If you want to connect with me, do it on TikTok.
If you want to connect with me,
Don't do it on the video number.
Go to TikTok and connect with me.
Yes, go to TikTok.
I sent a live link in our membership group.
a live streaming link.
to connect with me.
I'm like Ne Zha.
Yes, because the weather is hot now.
the weather is hot.
I basically don't have.
except when I need to appear on camera,
I might record a program,
or I'm going to meet someone,
Even when I meet girls, I wear this hairstyle.
You know.
Because it's rare enough.
Because it's attractive enough.
That's why I
You know, I do the opposite.
Because everyone is doing the same thing.
Everyone has the same hairstyle, the same
same actions,
same makeup,
and the same outfits.
So you need to
how to stand out.
What is the concept of standing out?
What is the concept of the peacock theory?
Do you know, brothers?
the concept of the peacock theory.
Some brothers say differentiation.
is that you need to be rare enough.
Okay.
you need to be scarce enough.
When everyone is like that,
you are not like that.
You don't care if you are ugly or good or anything else.
right?
but you still need to have a certain aesthetic.
You can't say everyone is very clean.
and you deliberately make yourself smelly and sloppy.
That won't work.
You have to be positive.
You have to stand out positively.
positive scarcity, okay?
Do you understand?
positive scarcity.
Wait a minute.
You must be positive scarcity.
New brothers,
Click the like button in the upper left corner.
please help me click the like button.
Click the like button.
Like it first, click the like button first.
And those who haven't joined
brothers who haven't joined my fan club yet,
spend one cent to light up my fan light card.
and become our old fan.
I'll answer your questions live every day.
I'll share useful knowledge with you every day.
Let you progress.
and gain emotional freedom.
You'll become a master at flirting with girls, you know?
Master of flirting.
How scary.
What a terrifying title.
Master of flirting.
and achieve your goal of learning one hundred words.
a Hundred Word Killer.
and become a master of BaiCiZhan.
Do you all have BaiCiZhan?
Do you have it?
Have you used BaiCiZhan today?
Brothers, have you used BaiCiZhan today?
If you haven't done the Hundred Words today,
then you need to study more.
you need to study more.
How many girls have I dated?
I won't say how many I've dated.
The number of girls I've dated is countless.
Just the ones I've dated,
the number of dates I've been on is countless.
But if you ask me
how many have you finished,
or how many I've slept with,
I can't even count them.
Because when I reached about sixty,
I stopped counting.
I stopped counting, really.
If I remember now,
I may not even remember some of them.
I can't even remember if I've dated them or not.
I don't know if you have this feeling.
After a long time,
you may forget whether there is such a person.
You may forget whether there is such a person.
There really is such a situation.
You have too many things to do.
your experience with women
all your experiences with women,
all the experiences,
have been experienced,
If you have the same
with two eyes and one mouth.
If he doesn't have a very
he doesn't make a deep impression on you,
If he doesn't make a deep impression on you,
and doesn't leave a deep impression on you,
You really can't remember him.
Some brothers say it's still a threshold issue.
It's the same for you.
Why do many people have fantasies?
You know the so-called Baicizhan.
the so-called BaiCiZhan.
Three words, BaiCiZhan.
Why are they just for losers?
or some people who haven't experienced
have such an experience.
Why? Why?
Why? Because if you eat the same thing too much,
unless you are a collector of quantity.
but you also need good skills,
good luck and enough patience.
You may be able to achieve Hundred Times斩.
However,
in most cases,
you eat the same thing every day.
You eat hot pot every day.
or eat steak every day,
You will get sick of it in the future.
Wait a minute.
At a certain point in the future,
one day in the future,
you will feel sick when you see steak.
You will vomit when you see hot pot, you know?
This is determined by
is determined by the dopamine threshold of the brain.
is determined by the dopamine threshold.
It's your dopamine
determines whether you can
whether you can do a hundred battles.
It's determined by your dopamine threshold.
You,
Some people
have a low dopamine threshold.
What kind of people?
Those who are prone to depression
and those who are prone to anxiety.
and anxious people.
Such people have a
have a very low dopamine threshold.
So they are prone to anxiety.
So they are prone to
After being satisfied,
After being satisfied, they start to
lose interest in it, you know?
It's hard for such people to reach a hundred exhibitions.
Only those who
it's hard to reach the dopamine threshold.
and dopamine threshold
can easily
It's not easy.
It's hard for them.
For the same thing,
you eat the same thing every day,
you will really get sick of it.
It's hard to reach a hundred.
So I really
I might have eaten over sixty bowls of rice.
I'm sick of this bowl of rice, guys.
I'm really sick of this bowl of rice.
So after that,
I don't want to count.
You know?
I don't want to remember.
And even before I reached sixty,
I don't have the habit of counting either.
I really don't care about this.
I focus on details
and technical means.
and technical level.
focus on teaching.
Maybe the replicability.
Okay, let's change the topic.
Yes.
A bro on TikTok said,
I focus on teaching.
is it easy to pick up foreign girls?
It's the same.
According to our five locking points for chatting up,
Which five locks?
For our new fans,
Let's explain to our new fans and brothers.
Which five locks?
Does anyone know?
What is the first one?
It's called force lock, right?
The first one is the strength lock.
You need to touch his shoulder first.
Why not call it shoulder touch lock?
Why not call it touch lock?
Why is it called force lock?
Because our strength has a standard.
there is a standard.
The first step is to lock the strength.
The first step is not the gaze.
nor the angle.
The first step is to lock the strength.
Touching his shoulder requires
with a certain amount of force.
Not like,
and hit them directly to fly away with great force.
or slap them to death.
nor too light.
Just a light touch,
like a sales weirdo.
Like a very lewd and
like a pervert who sexually harasses women.
Touching a woman lightly
This is also not okay.
That is to say, we have a standard strength.
After locking the strength,
what to do next?
then eye locking.
and then eye locking.
This eye lock is
immediately after the strength lock.
And after eye locking,
he can't leave immediately.
He also needs to lock for a period of time.
So this time
The time of this lock
we also have standards.
There are also standards for the locking time.
What comes after the eye lock?
It's the angle lock, the angle lock.
We also have a standard for this angle, you know?
We are at a forty-five degree angle to the outside.
not ninety degrees or one hundred eighty degrees.
It's forty-five degrees, remember forty-five degrees.
Okay, then your angle is locked.
you also need to lock the distance.
Do you understand distance locking?
we also have a standard distance.
It's a template.
All our behaviors in picking up girls
all the behaviors in it
are standardized.
It has indicators.
There are over one hundred tips for our pick-up.
It's not that you go up and
and just ask for a number.
It requires
We have a set of standard systems.
and a scoring system.
Whether you have done it standard or not.
No, you do.
As long as you standardize this thing,
its success rate will be very scary.
And the success rate
It's not about the success rate of collecting numbers, but
in the pick-up scene,
in the context of the pick-up scene,
you can gain a high level of attraction.
This is the logic.
We are not collecting numbers.
or even let the students
we ask them not to bring their phones.
not to touch their phones.
and let all the girls add him.
and let all the girls add him, you know?
This is our technical method.
The last lock, the last lock, right?
I just said four.
The last lock is our opening line.
We only say the opening line at this time.
Many people start with an opening line, you know?
This is the difference.
So you should say
If you ask me if it's easy to pick up foreign girls,
It's the same.
Because we have foreign students,
the same system is used for dating abroad.
You can still get results, you know.
you can still get results.
The only difference is your language.
Well, if your language is really bad,
you might just say excuse me,
I just want to say
Uh, you're absolutely beautiful.
Uh, I want your Instagram, right?
You can directly ask for his Instagram account.
or I want your WeChat, that's it.
It's very simple.
Take it easy.
Right?
First, you just need to lock in those few things,
and then say your opening line.
and then the attraction will come naturally.
The premise is that you have to do it standard, okay?
The premise is that you have to do it standard.
If you don't do it standard, you won't attract.
The woman may not understand what you said.
It's not that they don't understand.
but they doubt your intentions.
You are here to play with her.
to sell something,
or really come to flirt with her?
He will observe from your expression,
your body language
and from our entire set of
to observe from our standard.
Foreign girls can still be picked up.
using our system,
there is no difference.
There is no difference.
The difference is only in your words.
the problem of your language.
Okay, let's take a look.
This Gan Ning on the video account said
Can Jie Ge only use high value to get back?
You need to know.
Let me tell you.
Do you know how to bargain?
It's the brother Gan Ning.
The negotiation broke down.
You two broke down the negotiation.
The merchant said
I can only sell it for
I can only sell it for one hundred.
You can only ask for one hundred.
It can only be sold for one hundred.
The lowest price is one hundred.
You said no.
I'll take it for eighty.
Then you two broke off the negotiation.
You just turned around and left.
What does this represent?
It means that you turned around and left.
Later, you came back and said, Hey, can I sell it for one hundred?
I can sell it for one hundred.
He doesn't want to sell it to you at this time.
Why? What does it mean?
After you left,
you come back after the negotiation broke down.
What does this mean?
It means that you
you need this thing.
You need this thing.
You are just bargaining without limit.
At this time, I am a smart merchant.
One hundred twenty, one hundred fifty, no less.
Take it or leave it.
Okay, you will definitely buy it at this time.
because you have come back after a circle.
You find that
that you still need this thing.
So the need will come out, okay?
At this time, the sense of need emerges.
So saving a relationship means you fail to bargain,
and then you take a step back.
You will definitely be negotiated by others.
you will definitely be negotiated by others.
As long as you try to save the relationship,
you will definitely be negotiated by women.
Do you understand?
If you come back to bargain,
If you're not satisfied with the price she offers,
You can only understand.
You can only beg her.
So you must have a good reason.
why you should do high-value recovery.
That is, you need to do such a thing.
You saw a better price
you find a better price elsewhere.
They might sell it for ninety yuan.
and sell it for ninety.
But you are because
you have promised this merchant first,
and then you come back to buy from him, you know?
You need a good reason,
and excuse.
This is our high-value recovery.
I'm valuable now.
I have achieved results in fitness,
I have a better business,
and a better job.
I'm living a good life now.
but I'm still willing to choose you.
and I still want to chat with you.
Do you understand? You have to give girls
If you want to do a high-value recovery,
you must do it.
You must convey to the girl
to convey the message that
that I'm doing very well now,
but I'm still willing to choose you.
This is because of our previous relationship
and some of our previous experiences.
I care about it.
The premise is that you are living a good life.
and second, don't be a doormat.
and don't have a sense of need to talk to her about this.
Both are indispensable.
Your display surface,
your Moments,
your recent three-month state.
should be very good,
and awesome.
and okay.
This is value.
Then talk to her.
We also need to talk about technical things, not flattering.
not arrogant,
and neither humble nor arrogant.
Only in this way can you save it.
Do you understand? This is a very complex area.
and the success rate cannot be guaranteed, you know?
Why do we want to save it?
We talked about a key point.
Why do you want to save it?
to save a relationship means to be bargained.
That's one of the reasons I don't like to save it.
You just
To put it bluntly, bro,
You can't find such
a woman with big breasts and a big butt?
So you go back to her.
you go back to save her.
Why would someone want to save a relationship?
Isn't it because he has few resources, right?
Women all know that
the woman you're trying to save knows that
No, you don't.
You, a loser, have few resources.
You haven't found a girl after searching for a long time.
Why do you come to me again?
She definitely doesn't want to be so cheap.
She definitely won't agree to you.
So you need to express
high value, I have such high value,
I'm willing to come back to you.
Without this logic,
you can't make it.
With this logic,
you may still have a failure rate.
Understand? Don't try to save it.
Even if it's a huge loss,
You will lose your vitality, you know?
If you try to save him, it will take away your luck,
your self-confidence,
and your self-worth recognition.
Understand? He will destroy you.
So I don't recommend you to save him.
Isn't it different if you get more resources?
Right, you get more resources.
I don't believe it, right?
There are plenty of fish in the sea, right?
Save the relationship.
Remember this concept.
If you try to save it,
you will be bargained.
Bargaining means you have to be a dog.
Bargaining means you have to be a dog for him.
And being a dog doesn't necessarily mean you'll get bones.
Being a dog doesn't necessarily mean you'll get bones.
It's just possible that you'll be a dog.
Maybe you'll get a bone.
It's just possible.
Why bother, bro.
I know you really want to get her.
and want to possess her body.
and her soul.
But its impact on your future
and the impact on your inner core
is very, very huge.
is very terrifying.
Don't ignore this thing.
This thing may make you down and out.
Do you understand? You will waste
waste five, ten, or even a lifetime.
Because you are controlled by her.
You are firmly controlled by her.
You are completely controlled by her, got it?
You are locked by her.
You are hung up by her.
Is it worth being hung by her for a lifetime?
Brothers, is it cost-effective?
You are a man.
You are not a bitch.
Let's take a look at this guy on TikTok.
he said why he always runs out of energy when chatting with girls.
It means you're not good.
Your question is too broad.
It's too broad.
The scope is too broad.
You ask me why
why you are exhausted every time you chat with girls.
because your skills are too poor.
I can only answer you like this.
a conceptual answer.
So, so you have to ask me
something specific.
What did the woman keep sending?
or what you keep replying to her,
or she doesn't want to go out with you,
or he
or he talks nonsense with you,
They don't talk about feelings,
or relationship issues,
What's the reason for exhaustion?
Don't tell me
Why do I feel exhausted every time I talk to a girl?
Let's take a look. This bro on Douyin said,
can you give me some tips on appointment and attraction
for physical contact?
Let me tell you.
Have you seen my system?
This is the Unmeasured.
This bro
Have you seen my system?
Jackson flow.
Have you seen the real flow system?
I think there are some of your senior brothers here.
who studied with you.
They can answer this question for you.
Does anyone have a brother to answer this question?
The question he asked is, can you give some tips
some tips for physical contact in attraction?
He thinks pulling and attracting requires physical contact.
He thinks pulling and attracting depends on physical contact.
He thinks that upgrading the relationship requires physical contact.
Many things can be used to attract.
If you can cause his emotional fluctuations,
If you can cause his emotional fluctuations, there is attraction.
What, you just told a very
very nonsensical joke.
You said, I was on a date with a girl that day.
I picked my nose in front of her.
She said, why are you so disgusting?
You pick your nose.
I said, don't you pick your nose?
You pick your toes and boogers at home every day.
She laughed so hard.
Yes, I do.
Do you understand? You tell such a joke.
it will attract.
Attraction can be achieved in many ways.
You tell a narrative.
You said when I was a kid, I took um, I
From under my dad's bed.
I took it from under my dad's bed.
I was only in fourth grade at that time.
I found a bunch of
I found a bunch of discs.
I found a bunch of pornographic DVDs.
which were very pornographic.
very pornographic discs.
I took them out,
and put them in my schoolbag.
Then I took them to school to show my classmates.
I was reported by the study committee.
Then the teacher asked my parents to come.
I tell this narrative.
Girls can also get emotions.
and she will also be attracted.
Why do you still have such behavior?
Are you a naughty child?
Are you a sexual person?
Why did you start watching porn at such a young age?
Why did you come into contact with those things at such a young age?
Are you a
a very playful boy?
She will think in her mind.
You know, and then attraction comes.
Attraction doesn't come from physical touch.
Physical touch is when you do that
to flirt with her.
No, no, no, that's not it.
No, no physical touch.
It's not about physical touch.
Upgrading the relationship
and gain attraction.
It's not about physical touch.
Don't do physical touching.
I've been talking about it every day.
Every day, every day, everyday.
Every day's live broadcast
Every live stream,
Don't touch her physically.
Remember it.
The first rule of real stream.
The first rule of the real stream interpretation.
The first rule is not to touch women.
Don't touch women outside, okay?
Yes, what brother BN said is right.
Brother [M] is right.
Try to do fake skin contact in private space.
It is used for TQ in some situations.
What is TQ? What is TQ for?
What is it for?
Let's pay attention to our words.
Guys, let's pay attention to our words.
Because the domestic platform review is very strict.
If I were to do live streaming on YouTube,
to live stream on YouTube,
then I can speak very freely.
I can explain it clearly to you.
I can tell you about private space clearly.
All kinds of eighteen禁 content
I can explain it clearly.
But this is in China.
This is in China.
It's not allowed, okay?
What can attract people?
Brothers, it's very simple.
Watch my live stream.
how I grab it,
how I describe something.
what I'm saying,
or what I'm doing.
Do you understand that these are all called attraction?
These are all called attraction.
It's not because
I upgrade my body language.
I didn't touch you physically.
but I can still attract you.
Do you understand? This is called attraction.
Attraction attraction.
Okay.
Attraction.
This is called attraction.
Your words and deeds
your mental core
It's not because I'm handsome,
or how flirty I am, okay?
It's not because of my physical upgrades.
Right? I can still attract you.
So you think attraction is the so-called
physical touch or physical escalation?
No way.
It must be your words and deeds,
your whole composition,
your personal image,
Physical contact doesn't mean progress, right?
You can touch him, you can touch
some parts of his upper body.
doesn't mean you can be with him.
You can touch him,
It doesn't mean you can clap with him.
Many people
we talked about this thing a few days ago.
Many people, many novices,
and many beginners
many Chinese men
in their minds
what they think about is
I can do the first step.
what parts of her body I can touch.
and what parts of her body I can touch next.
What parts of her can I kiss next?
Next, I can reach some places.
Next step, I can insert into some places.
It's not like that.
It's not a fucking progress bar.
Physical touch is not a progress bar.
You will really kill yourself.
If you think so,
you will kill yourself.
Physical touch is not a progress bar, okay?
Let's take a look at what this guy on Bilibili said.
He said, Jie Ge can explain today.
The girl in the internal group said she minds tattoos.
Why do you have to face it?
His we.
His directness.
I want you to face up to his words.
It's his words.
If you mind, just don't meet.
This proves that this woman
I can use my experience,
and my emotional experience
and teaching experience,
I can instantly judge that this woman
is very sensitive.
This person is very sensitive.
and even before, he was
been stood up by many boys
and been cheated on by many boys.
Maybe they have met many times and talked about this.
You must face this problem directly, you know?
This problem is his inner demon.
This is his inner demon, you know?
It's his obsession.
You must solve it.
If you don't solve this problem,
he will make trouble with you because of this problem.
You can't handle it.
So we must face it directly.
Understand? You must face it directly.
But if you just lick her,
Your so-called friendliness and tolerance are fake. Why?
Because strangers
because others won't care.
they won't care about you for no reason.
If someone cares about you for no reason,
If a man
caring about a pretty girl for no reason,
or a woman,
it must be
Even a fool or a child knows why he would
to care about a woman for no reason.
Because he wants to get her.
Because he wants to sleep with her.
Okay.
Even a child knows.
Even men know.
Why do you think a woman
doesn't know what you want to do.
Why are you being friendly?
Type out that classic line for me.
Brothers in the internal group,
Your oil is good.
What's that called?
I can't say that in my live stream.
If you remember,
If you remember, type it out.
Your oil is good.
You are a friendly man.
friendly, friendly boy, friendly man.
There is a word, what is it?
I think there is a word that is very
There is a very classic word.
Friendly dog, friendly dog, this is very classic.
What's the Chinese for it? Good friend dog.
I think I think friendly
Of course, I'm not arguing here, bro.
Because I've seen many white knights.
I've seen many white knights.
I'm not arguing here.
Because you know, okay, to refute what?
I think it mainly refers to white knights.
Many white knights, many of them.
Many of them are friendly.
Many people even pretend to be gay
he pretends to be gay.
He pretends to be gay to
to applaud for this woman.
he pretends to be gay.
Then he is very friendly.
and very friendly.
I call this kind of people
Good friends, good friends, good friends.
Three words, good friends.
friendly dog.
What?
They shouldn't be called white knights.
They are not for
Why shouldn't they be called white knights?
Because knights are supposed to protect princesses.
Knight is fucking protecting the princess.
But these people don't want to protect the princess.
They just want to eat the princess.
They just want to kill the princess.
They just want to sleep.
So they are not white knights.
They are not white knights.
They are just friendly dogs.
So they shouldn't be called white knights, okay?
They shouldn't be called white knights.
They definitely shouldn't be called white knights.
I think it's an insult to the word knight.
It's an insult to the word knight.
It's so funny, good friend.
Uh, this word is so funny.
Let's take a look at this brother XO on Bilibili.
He said, Jie Ge,
how to speak and sound stable.
to give others a stable feeling.
Uh, just like I am now.
the range of my voice when I'm talking
is in the mid-low range, not very low.
There is no very low tone.
There is no very low sound.
It may be in the second or third octave.
There are no very low notes.
What is the midrange?
My current
my voice is in the middle register.
When I'm in a passionate mood,
You can't keep your voice so low.
For example, like Moke,
like a meditation flow.
Moke's voice is always in the low range.
I'm going to play a game with you now.
If I win, I will get a kiss.
That is, his voice is always at this level.
You can't keep it low.
If you keep it low, it's not stable.
If you keep it low,
not stable.
You will give people a very strange feeling.
For example, we have
On YouTube, for example,
For example, Master Ke.
he always has that kind of voice.
His voice is relatively consistent,
which can create a certain sense of mystery.
But it will be boring and sleepy after a long time.
So the best way
It's not that you keep being stable.
not to be stable all the time.
Remember this.
It's not that you keep being stable, okay?
It will make people want to sleep.
If I do this
If I live stream like this,
it will make you want to sleep.
You can listen to it as an ASMR.
Listen to it as a sleep aid, ASMR.
Do you know?
But we are a science popularization,
cognitive,
and technical.
and emotional live stream.
We need to have emotional connection.
When you're with a girl,
if you meet
if you meet a girl
who is attractive to you,
and you think she is attractive to you.
and she is very attractive to you,
you can say
you can keep saying that.
It's beneficial, it's one.
makes you feel that you are
very stable.
If you meet a girl
you can operate like this.
But if you encounter a yellow order,
and some windows are not so big,
If you use this way,
you will die.
You will die without a burial place, okay?
So you need to combine
emotion, voice, and state.
When you are in a low mood,
your voice should be relatively stable now.
When you are in a high mood,
you need a high level of physical coordination.
your voice,
and your state.
It should be in harmony.
This is the ultimate manifestation of expressive ability.
your impetuousness
or your high-pitched voice
it's not a flaw, you know?
This bro,
brothers,
your voices are high-pitched.
are not your shortcomings.
It's just that you use it in the wrong occasion.
So, sometimes you can use the low-pitched range,
and sometimes you use
high-pitched voices are okay.
It's okay to be comprehensive.
Don't deliberately lower your voice to a very low level.
I want to play a game with you.
If you win,
I'll get a quick kiss.
Don't do that, okay?
Is there any show effect?
Brothers, is there any show effect?
Brothers, is there any show effect in this live broadcast?
Is there any drama?
Is there any dramatic effect?
Okay, let's connect a mic first.
Bauer wants to connect with the mic.
If you open two,
then there may be an echo.
If you open this one,
If you open two platforms,
there will be an echo.
Normally, there shouldn't be any.
Bauer wants to connect with us.
Do you still need to connect?
If not, I'll connect with others.
Let's wait for him first.
Let's see the problem.
Um.
This brother on Douyin
this untested ownership.
He said if you don't kick out without appointment,
suggest that you can case it.
and then you need to accumulate progress again.
If you don't push the first appointment,
If you can case it,
you must do it.
This has been mentioned in our previous live stream.
you must case.
There's no problem with that.
This is correct.
Because if you don't reach the second appointment,
you don't TD in the first appointment,
you don't reach a certain progress,
you have to accumulate again.
to accumulate the progress bar.
So, if you don't TD,
you also need to do a
high-level physical contact.
He's not on the mic now.
Okay, I'll connect with you first.
Let's connect first.
Hello, brother Jie.
Can you hear me?
Wait a moment, let me turn on the sound.
Oh.
Can you hear me now?
Uh-huh.
Okay, I have a question for you, um, about a date.
about One Date.
I had a one-night stand with a girl yesterday.
I met her by chatting her up.
Yes.
During the date, um,
she said she was a very contrasting girl.
She looks more experienced,
but actually very traditional inside.
Then I wasn't there.
I accidentally brought up the topic of sex.
And then she said that she could only
only accept sex after marriage.
Yeah.
And I followed up with
a Platonic framework.
I said that
actually
but it was actually a fake follow-up,
Because he followed up with me
and we went back to this topic.
I asked him later,
Are you the one who separates sex from love?
he said yes.
He said that if he really loved someone,
he can do anything, but
he could put the X after marriage for her.
You go first.
You, he now.
what he means is not
that he separates X and I.
He said they are inseparable.
And then he means that
He said this part.
what he just said.
he might have misunderstood your meaning.
Then I told him that
If I
I can't do this anyway.
If I love someone deeply,
I would naturally want to be close to him.
Isn't this exposing your neediness?
At this time, it's not
it's not about values.
At this time,
he will recognize your need.
You said you, you said.
He said, he just said,
He said he loved
even if he loves you,
he will get married.
and then what after that.
If you follow this thing again,
That actually reveals your sense of need.
Anyway, I feel that there is
I'm a little bit confused.
And then during the date,
she said I had many values
values had a big impact on her.
She said it was like a cognitive baptism.
Um.
It's him, you,
If you recognize that he
who looks very slutty
and very slutty.
then it's okay.
He is a quiet pervert, right?
He is a quiet and shy person.
That's for sure.
Right?
I'm a little bit out of him.
Just agree with him.
Just agree with his framework.
You don't need to at this time
to express what you want.
Because if you say it at this time,
at this time,
You can say it before
he didn't mention
he didn't say what he must do after marriage.
narrative,
you can express your own
such values.
But at this point,
he says what he must do after marriage,
If you talk about your own,
That actually confirms your need.
Do you understand?
It does feel a bit
At this point, you should at least not say it.
If he says something that you don't agree with,
you don't agree with it,
You can say it's quite good.
I think your
I can't say I fully agree with it,
but I think
but I definitely don't disagree.
You just laugh it off.
Oh.
He will reach a certain level of emotion with you,
and have TD with you.
Yes, indeed, brother Jie.
I shouldn't argue with him logically.
Don't try to reason.
Don't try to reason with him.
Especially if he has already given
If he gives a vague answer,
You can try to use
three values to battle.
You can use three values to fight with him.
But his background is very clear.
that he is white,
and what you say is black.
It's hard to influence him.
Yes, that's right.
using logic to fight is
it's hard to influence him.
So you just say something like, um-hmm.
I think it's not bad.
Well, you girls like you
there are many girls like you.
Okay, bro Jie.
I've met girls like this who feel
I'm a little helpless with traditional girls.
Now,
Actually, you can't.
It's just that she's with you now.
Her mask hasn't been taken off.
You just need to go along with her.
When you arrive in the private space,
what you should do, do you understand?
You can adjust it.
His willpower
his willpower cannot overcome his body's reactions.
Let me tell you,
Human willpower is very fragile.
It can't overcome his physical reactions.
We have a good brother Jie's instinct.
to catch people, human nature, animal nature.
Thank you, Brother Jie.
Um.
I'll get off the mic now.
Let Brother Baoer ask questions.
Okay.
You can summarize what we just talked about.
what kind of useful information we just heard.
It's still one of our
what is the dry goods we talked about before?
The Procrastination.
It's very powerful.
I think this is the biggest trick I have used in my life.
The word Tuo.
The biggest trick I've used in my life
the greatest trick is the Procrastination.
Okay, let's start the next live connection.
Hello.
Can't hear you.
Is anyone there?
What's up, bro?
Why did you use the procrastination trick?
In the previous episodes,
I've talked about this thing in previous livestreams.
And now we continue to
and we continue to talk about this.
And there's a replay on Bilibili.
You can watch it later, okay?
You can watch it later.
Wait a minute, I'll get a power bank.
Take this, take a power bank.
One of my phones is out of power.
Okay, let's continue.
Why couldn't we connect the mic just now?
Is there any problem?
Let's continue to connect the mic.
Hello.
Hello, hello, hello, I still can't hear you.
Are you plugged in headphones?
Don't plug in headphones.
Don't connect the earphones.
Don't connect to any microphones or anything.
Why can't I hear you?
Check if the mic is turned on here.
Check your settings on Douyin.
or permissions.
If it doesn't work, use the video account.
You can also use the video account.
Let's answer a question from another bro first.
You can get off the mic.
Let's answer another question from our brothers first.
Why does Brother Jie tie his hair up?
It's too hot.
His hair is long and it will fall down.
Hair will fall here.
Eyes will be covered.
It's hot.
and uncomfortable.
Hey.
Hey, can you hear me, Jie Ge?
Oh, I can hear you.
Okay, okay.
I have a few questions.
Um.
First of all, today
Today, I sent in the group
posted my display surface.
I think there are some problems.
I mainly want to ask you about
to ask you for advice.
Oh, this is some useful information.
Ah ah.
First of all, I want to ask
how do you usually choose
how you choose the location.
Um.
I can only give you a general idea.
Because if I directly give you
it's actually some of our commercial secrets.
Okay.
Ah, I see, I see.
I can only give you a general idea.
Just choose a cultural and creative community.
Pick a cultural and creative community, right?
Yes, just choose some cultural and creative communities.
On Xiaohongshu,
search for check-in and photo-taking.
It depends on your own aesthetic.
depends on your own taste.
The location is good.
It should be a little artistic,
Right?
To be honest,
you can find a nice street.
it's also okay.
You don't have to say it's very artistic.
It depends on your own aesthetic.
In fact, on the street,
you can see many posts
with hundreds of thousands of likes.
You know, hundreds of thousands of likes.
or even hundreds of thousands likes on TikTok.
Yeah.
or some Taobao models,
they really just go to a street
and set up a machine to take photos.
Okay, okay, okay.
And then there is this.
the value that needs to be displayed in the display.
Can you give me some examples?
First, our offline management.
Yes.
I saw your display surface.
your lower limit management is very poor, right?
You also pointed out the bar.
Yes.
Lower limit management is part of
in our display surface system,
a real stream
system, it's very important.
an important point about the presentation.
If you solve the lower limit management,
your presentation will not be bad.
You put seven or eight photos,
Seven or eight, six or seven, right?
Six or five.
Five pictures, just five.
I think putting three photos is better than five.
Or if you really put two less,
will be better than your current effect.
Do you understand?
Don't put too many pictures.
or to fill it up
Don't fill it up with some
putting some junk things on it.
Do you know?
There is a saying that
A rat shit can spoil a pot of soup.
This is the best example of
an excellent manifestation, you know?
you need to do a good job in offline management.
Then your
your and mine
you need to show.
If you want to show off,
you must show your class.
If you want to meet higher-quality girls,
you need to show your class.
Class doesn't mean you go here and there to play.
Fill all the nine-square grids.
I tell you,
Those who post in Moments
and top ten posts.
with ten or twenty posts.
and each one is filled with nine-square grids.
Those people who post
his resources won't be good.
What?
I know this.
His resources may be very abundant.
but they are all low-quality.
but all of them are low-quality.
If you have something like
You have a cruise to Antarctica.
a display of going to Antarctica to play.
One display will be enough to kill them all.
all those tourism things.
He's smart.
You need to think more about this, you know.
You need to make yourself more elite.
instead of just
We still need to show ourselves here.
to stand out.
stand out.
It means your display should be different from others.
I um.
We did some shows before.
Hank did some shows, right?
He asked him and his
he filmed a show with his PY.
And then that PY said this.
They were evaluating
who's display, right?
Do you remember that episode?
Do you remember?
Uh.
I know.
he was evaluating someone's display.
And then the woman
the guest of Tanken.
She said that the person in this display
this guy is a German fanatic.
At first hearing,
you might think that the woman is praising the man.
He is a German fanatic.
Then I should learn from this German idiot.
and learn from his presentation.
Did you think like this?
No.
I think she thinks that this man
is deliberately doing these things to fish.
That's probably what he thinks.
She means this man is smelly, dirty,
and very low.
Ah, right?
Yes.
So what you need to do is to distinguish yourself from them.
I post photos.
Let me tell you.
This is straight to the point.
This is fucking干货.
When I post photos on my Moments,
I won't post more than two photos at a time.
More than eighty percent of them are one photo.
I take a scene.
I take a set of outfits,
or take a set of outfits,
or show something.
I might take twenty or thirty photos,
but I don't care.
even if there are ten good-looking photos,
or five good-looking ones,
I don't care.
I only need one.
and throw away the others.
I just pick the best one.
Yes, I only need one.
and throw away the others.
I got it.
Let me tell you what this principle is called.
Michelin plate.
Do you understand?
Understood.
You go to a restaurant,
or a small restaurant,
A plate is full of meat and vegetables.
Hurry up.
It's delicious, but
Would you take a photo of it and post it on Moments?
Definitely not.
Because it
It looks bloated.
Because it's too much.
Too much is bad.
and cheap.
You know, too much is too greasy.
So you need a Michelin-style plate.
a plate the size of a face,
a ceramic plate,
Put a piece in the middle.
just put one piece.
This is the sense of luxury.
Wow!
This is the sense of high class.
It's true.
So in the future, your WeChat Moments,
do a good job in offline management.
and then apply the Michelin rules
and the Michelin plate arrangement rules.
Wait for me for two minutes.
Other aesthetic things
you can't handle them in a short time.
And that's not
It can't be explained in a few words.
It's a practical action.
Even if I give you the dry goods,
I tell you how to compose,
how to shoot from that angle,
and how to get light.
Can you understand these things?
You can't understand it, right?
So, we don't talk about those professional
we don't talk about professional things.
Let's clarify the concepts.
It's your offline management.
offline management.
What else?
Uh, the things you just mentioned,
such as composition,
Actually, I have some knowledge about
I have some understanding of them.
I am now
because my friend and I both
We both like taking photos.
I have a general understanding of it.
I have an opinion now.
I don't know if you agree with it.
I think generally,
I feel that in general,
the frontal shot should be relatively rare.
unless you are very good-looking.
pure frontal shot.
Here is a tip.
Everyone take note.
You can't take a frontal selfie with a third party.
It can't be taken by a third party.
Yes, it can only be selfies.
Oh.
OK, I'll write it down.
But if you only take selfies of your face,
the camera will distort your face
will distort a lot, right?
No, just turn on the two times.
Oh, yes yes yes.
Yes, yes.
Yes yes.
Yes, indeed.
And then one thing is that
I think, I think,
I saw some of Bingge's
the display surfaces he posted on Moments.
I saw that many of them, basically
were taken indoors.
Outdoors, right?
Only in those places
on the street,
or some other places.
just in that kind of
For example, in a pure
like in the mountains
those with natural scenery.
it's more
a more unique place
unique place.
On the street.
If we're being strict,
can be filmed.
It depends on your composition and aesthetics.
OK.
It doesn't mean that
a specific location.
OK.
And then,
about the clothes
the choice of the style.
I just want to ask more specifically,
For example, in summer,
should you try to choose
should be with shoulder pads
or a looser one
to make your shoulders look wider.
You don't need to care about it when taking photos.
You don't need to worry about these when taking photos, right?
I'll give you a tip for taking photos.
Don't wear shoulder pads or height-increasing shoes for photos.
Got it, okay.
I don't have it.
I don't have them.
This is what someone told me.
Many idiots think
they think that when taking photos,
shoulders
shoulder pads and height-increasing shoes.
But in fact, when you take photos,
people will know that you are wearing them.
and it looks very strange.
Because of your standing and sitting posture,
will be padded up,
will be very bulky.
It doesn't look good when you take a photo.
You can edit the photos, right?
You can edit the photos.
Why do you want to pad your shoulders?
You can edit photos more naturally than padding shoulders.
Yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes.
Yes.
Ok.
Then there is the issue of the photography style.
I think
I saw that
I'm observing that
I can only see
just the WeChat Moments of the mentors.
I saw that
the WeChat Moments of the mentor Han Hans.
he released some sample photos.
that is
there are some from Bi Dao,
and Bin's.
And then I saw that
I think they both
their styles seem to be created to be
like wearing a leather jacket,
wearing leather jackets,
and a more masculine image, which is me.
But I think you, Brother Jie,
your
I think your sample photos are more
more elite,
and commercial elite.
It's about the style
the image of this display.
how to choose this kind of
No.
This is me, I show
I show myself as the head of the company
as a leader
role to show business.
I didn't show
my personal life.
Oh, right.
It's just that the things I show are different.
I don't post any of these in my own Moments.
In my own account for flirting with girls,
there is not a single one of these business photos.
All of them are about youthfulness,
and some of them are like husbands.
Okay.
And then why
Why do you set
like Bin Ge
and [B] Director, you set it to
like in The Godfather,
wearing a suit
style.
Is there any idea for this?
That's the design idea.
That's right.
It's for business.
It's not for flirting with girls.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Don't use this to
Don't use this picture to pick up girls, okay?
I see.
And then I saw an opinion online
a viewpoint.
which is called display surface.
like
which is life-like.
What do you think of this view?
I think many
are based on this view.
and then build their accounts.
I think it's because
Because of life.
for example,
they require you
For example, you need to post four pictures.
one of which is yourself,
and the other three are all about
such as a simple cup of coffee
or something like that.
How do you think of this way?
I don't recommend it.
Okay.
Because let me explain the principle.
If you post a cup of coffee
or a landscape,
it's easy to be thought of as stealing pictures.
So whether it's a cup of coffee or something else,
you should be in it.
This is life.
For example,
they want to post a four-square grid,
that is, one of the four pictures is you,
and the other three must
must be related to your life.
That's what they mean.
They just copy from each other.
Anyway, I don't read these things.
I follow my own practical experience.
I'll use whatever works well.
OK, OK, OK.
I definitely trust Jie Ge's experience.
Uh.
And then the last question is
it's about
I'm trying to gain muscle now.
I'm gaining muscle now.
And because I'm the kind of person
I'm one hundred eighty-three centimeters tall, but
I don't know my overall weight.
it has been around seventy-five kilograms.
but it just doesn't go up.
I work out every day.
I work out every day,
And I also control my diet.
I eat protein every day
protein and other nutrients.
I also take fish oil
and some supplements.
But I don't know why,
my weight just can't go up.
In terms of gaining muscle,
do you have any experience?
Eat less carbs.
Less carbohydrates.
Yeah.
Yes.
But before, SIMSIM said that
Before, SIMSIM was in the group.
He said that we should try to
to quit eating rice.
or something else?
He was talking about losing fat.
Let me tell you.
Let me tell you something.
From a nutritional point of view,
building muscle and losing fat cannot be done simultaneously.
That is, the more you lose fat,
how much you lose fat,
your muscle gain will be reduced by the same amount.
How much muscle you gain,
your fat loss will be reduced by the same amount.
I see.
You have too little glycogen.
You must grow slowly.
From now on, you need to
You should train harder to gain muscle.
Eat more carbs.
When you're big enough,
After a year of training,
Then you can start to lose fat.
But during this period,
your picking up girls or anything else
you will have problems.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, I'll go first.
I think I still need to gain some weight first.
because I feel like I'm a little bit
a little bit skinny.
My shoulders
my proportion is actually okay.
My shoulders are wide in person,
but I look a little thin.
That's all for now.
We have other brothers to talk to.
OK, OK.
OK, thank you, bro Jie.
Thank you, bro Jie.
That's all.
OK.
OK, I'll hang up first.
Um.
The two brothers who are connected to the mic on the video account.
you can only connect to the mic if you are our internal student.
If you are our internal student,
in the membership group,
you can send a request to connect to the mic.
and tell us your name
video account and your name on this
name on this social media, okay?
You can tell us your name.
and then we'll start the connection.
Watch the video or the replay on TV?
Bilibili has replay.
Bilibili has replay, okay?
Okay, let's continue to answer
questions from our TikTok brothers.
Let's hurry up,
because time is running out.
I thought it was a way to do hairstyle.
Yes, there is also a way to do hairstyle now.
It's concise,
and at the same time
It looks good, doesn't it, guys?
Is this hairstyle okay?
It looks okay.
I haven't done it yet.
I haven't put anything on my head.
There's nothing on my head.
I'll put some more products on it to style it.
The hairstyle will look better.
Do something like this, you know?
Add some hair down.
or do a hairstyle.
It will look very good.
I suggest you learn my hairstyle.
Don't do the goddamn broken hair or oily hair.
and don't do those anymore.
I'll tell you the real dry goods.
Follow the trend, okay?
the version that follows the times.
The real dry goods.
My hairstyle is the real deal.
I tell you my hairstyle is all about it.
My hairstyle is attraction.
Can I share songs?
Why do you need a playlist?
Bro, why do you want a playlist?
You tell me the purpose of your playlist first.
so I can recommend it to you.
Hair growth strategy, I talked about it the other day.
Didn't I talk about it two days ago?
I talked about hair growth strategy two days ago.
If you have hair loss,
If you have receding hairline,
Go and have your hair transplanted from the back to the front.
to the front.
Spend a few thousand.
Spend thousands or tens of thousands yuan.
to the front.
Then let it grow for a while.
What medicine should you take?
Finasteride.
to lower your androgen.
It can be maintained.
If you really don't want to take medicine,
Wait until you get married.
Wait until you're done playing, right?
Wait until you've had enough fun.
You can't have both, right?
I don't want to take medicine.
I want to look good.
Then I tell you it's impossible.
Let's take a look.
Let's take a look at the question this bro on TikTok asked.
Jie Ge just hit on a pair of twins.
I told my bestie that I know your friend.
My bestie agreed.
The target left.
What happened?
I've talked about this before.
I talked about this in the first live stream.
It seems that when I was reviewing with John,
Listen to the replay of my first live stream on Douyin.
On Bilibili, search for Real Social Jason.
Search for Real Social Jason, and you can.
you can watch our first live replay.
and you'll know how to solve it.
There is a specific method mentioned there.
It's a paid skill we offer offline.
I gave it to him.
You can listen to it again
and learn it.
Let's continue to answer questions.
Guys, don't ask any new questions.
We'll end the live stream after answering a few more questions.
Answer quickly.
Then Lives join this brother said, Jie Ge,
If you only want to put two photos,
if you want to highlight the scenery,
and it feels forced to be in the shot, what should I do?
Um.
For the scenery,
you can take a horizontal photo.
If you want to highlight the scenery,
if you want to highlight the scenery,
you can take a horizontal image of sixteen to nine ratio,
you can both highlight the scenery
and the person in the frame.
This is not deliberate.
Don't put a vertical image.
and then people are there.
Otherwise, the scenery cannot be highlighted.
Let's continue to answer.
Wu Yue said that
how does Jie Ge know that his
his experience and methods are correct
and how to find the correct method after finding errors.
find the correct method and idea.
Pay for a mentor.
Pay for an experienced person.
You won't go the wrong way.
It will take many years to figure it out by yourself.
If your time cost is not enough,
and money,
and your funds are sufficient,
then this method is for you.
If you don't have enough money or time,
but you have enough time,
then you can learn by yourself.
But it will take more time, okay?
You can only say that you can
you can come to us every day to ask questions,
and come to solve your problems every day.
and detailed questions.
so that you can learn faster.
This is a benefit for you.
It's a free benefit.
Let's take a look at what this guy named An Dun Dan said.
What should I do if I keep approaching girls?
How long should I follow?
Stop it, stop it.
Stop it. Who told you to follow her?
Who told you to follow?
Stop it, you know?
You must stop her.
If you don't stop,
Your frame is weak.
He won't talk.
and he won't be attracted to you.
You must do the stop.
Don't follow.
Today's Q&A session is over.
and the live broadcast time is over.
Tomorrow, at the same time, nine o'clock,
we will continue to live stream
and we'll solve your problems through the mic.
and give you more dry goods.
This is Jackson Flow, see you next time.
The last sentence.
Let's say it together.
Parents teach us to eat,
knowledge is taught by teachers.
Who to ask for help in finding a partner?
Brothers, you have five seconds to type.
Parents teach us to eat,
knowledge is taught by teachers.
Who to ask for help in finding a partner?
OK, that's it.
See you next time.